it's been a really long time that I have
dreamed for this and he not just me all
people from Kosovo especially athletes
so yeah finally the dream is coming true
I have been doing judo almost 16 years I
was quiet I didn't talk so much but when
I did do that I I was completely
different I was strong I was aggressive
I was a fighter
when I started it was a hard situation
in Kosovo for everything there was a lot
of kids who lost their parents a lot of
kids who doesn't have anyone from their
family because they lost them in in war
but anyway from this country I became
the best judoka in the world
if you just really want something you
have to work hard for this and don't
think so much where you live and to say
I can do it I can do it from here it's
hard because if you really want
something nothing can stop you I became
the best in the world and I had just my
coach I had nothing more I never had
doctor I still don't have doctor I just
love what I do and yeah I believe in
myself I believe in in what I do
Oh